he came to office more than a year ago
promising to fight corruption and
restore iranian's trust in their
government
ibrahim raici was the former head of
iran's judiciary who won the
presidential election securing nearly 63
percent of the votes in the lowest
turnout since the 1979 revolution only
49 percent of the public voted reyesi
campaigned to reduce unemployment
inflation and address a growing housing
problem
but it's been a challenging first year
in office with iran's economy continuing
its decline
inflation is around 40 percent the
unofficial unemployment rate hovers
around 30 to 35 percent with nearly 60
percent of the population now living in
poverty
economic uh stagnation and
corruption remains a key challenge for
the reyes administration and
nobody is expecting this to be fixed or
resolved within a short period of time
one year is not sufficient
to see that happening
he needs more time president raisi isn't
just fighting to save the economy but
attacks like this also highlight the
difficulties facing iran's security
apparatus on may 22nd in south tehran
two armed men on a motorcycle opened
fire on a vehicle driven by general
hassan sayat
of the revolutionary guards the general
died on the spot
iranian officials blamed israel and the
president said this
the serious pursuit of this issue by the
security officials is emphasized by me
and i have no doubt that the revenge of
the pure blood of this great man is
inevitable
three days later another suspicious
incident in the town of parchin near the
capital at one of the heavily fortified
military compounds the incident killed
the defense ministry engineer essan
katpeighi
there's been no official word about the
cause of his death
the other issue dominating raises first
year in office has been the diplomatic
effort to restore the landmark 2015
nuclear agreement
these talks are aimed at bringing the
united states and iran back to full
compliance the deal saw iran limit its
nuclear program in exchange for
sanctions relief
a deal israel has strongly criticized
and said it will not prevent it from
doing what it needs to do to stop iran
from developing a nuclear weapon
those talks have now reached the stage
where a draft agreement has been
presented according to the european
union foreign policy chief joseph perel
that will require serious political will
from officials in tehran and washington
the two sides are now exchanging notes
on that text and what happens next will
not only have far-reaching ramifications
for millions of iranians but it will
also define ibrahim raisi's first term
in office
doors to jabari al-jazeera tehran